and this is what behavior therapists do
they decompose your problems what are
you afraid of well okay you're afraid of
everything
well let's get something specific you're
afraid of well I'm afraid of an elevator
okay an elevator so I have a client
she's afraid of elevators the elevator
door open she goes that's a tomb and I
thought oh wow I thought it was an
elevator but for you it's not a bloody
elevator it's death and so that's what
you're afraid of it's worse than that
you're afraid of being trapped inside
there in the dark alone alone not
knowing if anyone is going to rescue you
stuck there with your damn imagination
freaking out it's like and if that's not
and then maybe you have a heart attacks
because you're so terrified and you die
it's like you know so that's the
elevator
well it's no bloody wonder there no
one's gonna get into something like that
and then maybe underneath that is your
distrust in the mechanisms of society
right because you know a normal person
those weird creatures they'll get an
elevator what the hell they don't care
and partly it's because they have an
implicit belief even if the thing stops
somebody will come along and rescue them
and usually you don't even think about
it
right it's like no what the hell it's an
elevator it's like the danger is
invisible to you and it's partly because
you implicitly trust the structure and
so maybe you go into the unconscious
presuppositions of the person who is
terrified of the elevator in the subways
and you find out they have a real
problem with trusting Authority that's
partly why they don't get along with
their husband why they've never been
able to stand up for themselves so then
you say okay well you're afraid of the
damn elevator but it's not an elevator
it's a tomb and the tomb is partly you
and partly it's partly the elevator and
partly your unconscious mind and so well
what can you handle can you go and look
at an elevator from 10 feet away it's
like yes okay how about 9 feet away yes
5 feet yes 4 feet no okay no problem
four and a half feet we're gonna go from
that elevator we're gonna look at the
damn thing until you're bored of it
because that's what we're trying to you
should be bored of the elevator because
then you're not afraid of it obviously
it's like it's an elevator you just
don't notice it right all these things
around here that you don't
notice I'd take you out of here and ask
you what color the walls are you haven't
got any idea you know yeah I suspect for
most of you there's not a chance you'd
be able to identify the gender of the
person who's sitting next to you unless
you know them it's like you just don't
remember anything and why should you
everything works like you don't have to
pay attention to it it's like is that
staying up yeah it's still up yeah still
up still up if it's like really no you
know you get bored of that real quick
and so then you just ignore it and but
the agoraphobic has had that veil of
ignorance torn away and what they see
behind it is mortal threat and so that's
really what you're helping them deal
with and so this week there are four and
a half feet from the elevator next week
they're a foot from the elevator in the
week after that the horrible gates of
Hell open and they look inside and they
don't run and so hey they're tougher
than they thought they were and that's
what you're teaching them actually
you're not teaching them that the world
isn't dangerous because that's a stupid
thing to teach someone bloody right the
world is dangerous it's terrifying and
sometimes people under they realize that
and the veil lifts and they see horror
everywhere they see that and then they
think well I'm just a little rabbit I'm
over here in the corner I can't move I'm
petrified and then they can't move they
hide it home they cower at home because
everything has become a predatory domain
and so what you teach them is you're not
as much of a rabbit as you think
and part of that is that you help them
grow some teeth so that they can go home
and have that fight with their husband
that they should have had 25 years ago
and it happens very frequently with a
agoraphobic clients that you get them so
they can go on the damn elevator and
they can go on the subway and they can
take a taxi it may be they learn to
drive Wow
they get some autonomy and then they're
a little tougher and so then they can
stand up from loot for themselves and
they go back and like their husband
might not be very happy with any of this
really it depends on what sort of guy he
is you know if he's a real tyrant he
might be just perfectly happy that he's
married to someone who you know was
afraid of her own shadow because then
she won't ever leave and so that's a
nasty little story and believe me it's
not
common so she gets tougher by facing
what she fears and what she finds out is
there's a hell of a lot more to her than
she thought and that's really what
happens when you do behavior therapy
with someone who's agoraphobic it isn't
really that they get less afraid it's
that they get braver that's way
different it's because brave is alert
and able to cope naive is there's no
danger it's like hell yeah right there's
no danger Jesus what a stupid theory
that is